The Silk Road was the first true communications network...
...that dates back 2,000 years.
Its land route start from Xian, China to Istanbul, Turkey...
...and then to Greece and Italy.
My research begins at Xian.
It's a land of diverse ethnic identities, and the Silk Road's eastern gateway.
Like the Internet, information and ideas spread rapidly along it...
...and this includes religious philosophy and teachings.
As the story goes, a Chinese pilgrim Xuanzang traveled 17 arduous years to India...
...in search of sacred Buddhist sutras.
Upon his return, the sutras he had found were placed in this magnificent pagoda.
Built in the 7th Century, the great mosque is one of the largest and best preserved.
You'll be even surprised to find as I was that it's completely Chinese in its architecture.
As I discover more about Xian and the Silk Road,...
...I realize that it shares some qualities with the modern Internet.
It's the first information highway where trade, art, and philosophy flourished.
And in addition to commercial exchanges,...
...it encouraged the historic multicultural exchange of epic proportions.
Olly Steeds signing off in Xian, China.